في غضون ذلك اعلنت وزاره التحول الرقمي
الاوكراني اليوم تفعيل صافرات الانذار في
مقاطعاتي خاركف وبولتافا وسومي ومناطق
اخرى في اوكرانيا للتحذير من غارات جويه
الى جانب الجزء الذي يسيطر عليه نظام كيا
في مقاطعه
من حيث انت كيف تتابع اخر المستجدات
والتطورات على الارض
في الواقع السفيان تمت متغير جدي لمسناه
خلال الساعات الماضيه وقد ترجم هذا الامر
على كامل خط الجبهه وتقاطعه مع تصريحات
رسميه اوكرانيه سواء من نائبه وزير الدفاع
او حتى من البيانات التي تصدر عن قياده
الاركان من الواضح ان زمام المبادره الان
قد اصبحت في يد القوات الروسيه التي تهاجم
عند اكثر من جبهه واكثر من موقع على طول
خط الجبهه الممتده من خاركاب مرورا
بيلوغاسك نتحدث عن هذه المقاطعات الشرقيه
الثلاث قبل شهرين عندما انطلقت انطلق
الهجوم الاوكرانيه المضاد كان الزمان
المبادره مع القوات الاوكرانيه ولكن من
الواضح انه منذ اسبوع حتى الان تغير
المشهد كليا هنالك محاولات للتقدم ومعارك
عنيفه تدور على كامل خط الجبهه بين القوات
الروسيه والاوكرانيه لمسنا هذا الامر من
خلال كم القصف الصاروخي الذي كنا نسمعه
منذ صباح اليوم ومن خلال الاليات والعت
الاوكرانيه الذي كان يتوجه الى تلك النقاط
ضمن خط الجبهه الممتد من كوبيانسك مرورا
بالايمان وصولا الى اباخ موت افديكا
ومارينكا عمليا متغيرات كثيره الضغط
الروسي بالامس كان فيه جوله في كوبيانسك
والتي تعتبر احد المراكز الرئيسيه لمحاوله
التقدم الروسيه اليوم كان هنالك تصريحات
من عدد من المسؤولين الاوكرانيا يتحدثون
عن قصف يستهدف كامل منطقه كوبيانسك
ومحاوله للتقدم الروسيه مما ادى الى مقتل
عدد من المدنيين بالاضافه الى التحام بين
الجيشين في تلك المنطقه في محاوله من
القوات الروسيه التقدم والوصول الى احكام
الطوق على مدينه التي كانت قد فقدت
السيطره عليها في سبتمبر الماضي هذا الامر
ينسحب ايضا على الايمان وعلى بخموت في
باخموت عندما كانت قياده الاركان
الاوكرانيه تتحدث قبل اسابيع عن محاولات
تقدم من جنوب المدينه وتحقيقها سيطره على
بضعه كيلوم اليوم تاتي البيانات كي تشير
الى ان القوات الروسيه هي من تدع زمام
المبادره وتحاول مهاجمه تلك المنطقه هذا
الامر بات يمتد على كامل الخط المواجهه في
شرط البلاد وهذا متغير جدي ذلك ان
القيادات الاوكرانيه كانت تتحدثا عن تقدم
لها اليوم تتحدث عن صد محاولات الهجوم هذا
ما قالته النائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
اليوم في حديثها الصباحي اكدت بان الوضع
وصفته بانه وضع دقيق للغايه في تلك
الجبهات وان القوات الاوكرانيه تصد
الهجمات التي تقوم بها القوات الروسيه
ايضا بالامس كان له حديث وقبل امس ايضا
عندما وصف الوضع بانه بات صعب للغايه في
هذه الجبهه وان كان قد عطف على كلامي هذا
بان السيطره الميدانيه ما زالت حتى هذه
اللحظه للقوات الاوكرانيه ولكن ضمن الجوله
التي قمنا بها بالامس على طول هذا الخط
لمسنا بانه هنالك تحركات اوكرانيا ودفع
بمزيد من القوات الى تلك المنطقه في
محاوله لمنع القوات الروسيه من احداث
ثغرات وتغيير في الخارطه الخارطه
الميدانيه لاسيما ان الهجوم المضاد لم
يؤتي اكله حتى الان مازال ابقى معنا اذهب
اليك نور الدين مع استمرار الهجوم
الاوكراني المضاد ماذا في الروايه الروسيه
بكل تاكيد الروايه الروسيه يبدو انها تنهج
استراتيجيه عسكريه قد تبدو جديده خاصه بعد
الزيارات التي قام بها وزير الدفاع شويغو
الى المنطقه الشماليه والشماليه الغربيه
والزياره التي قام بها رئيس هيئه الاركان
الى الجبهه الجنوبيه يبدو ان هناك تغير في
الاستراتيجيه العسكريه للرز باتجاه القوات
الاوكرانيه ويبدو انها مفتوحه على جميع
الجبهات واشغال القوات الاوكرانيه في جميع
الجبهات هناك اعاده موضوع للقوات الروسيه
في البحر الاسود من مضيق الى داخل البحر
الاسود واعاده تموضع للاسطول البحري
الروسي ربما هذا يعد استراتيجيه لمنع اي
ثغره لنفوذ القوات الاوكرانيه الى داخل
الموانئ الروسيه هناك خاصه بعد التهديدات
القادمه من كيا بان هناك محاوله استهداف
للموانئ لذلك نشهد اعاده تغيير تموقع
وتموضع للقوات الروسيه كذلك يمكن ربط جبهه
البحر الاسود في الجبهه الجنوبيه
وبالتحديد نتحدث عن ذابولوجيا وعن خرسون
قبل ايام كانت هناك المبادره العسكريه
خاصه في زبولوجيا الى القوات الاوكرانيه
ما ياتي الان من المعلومات القادمه من
الجبهه العسكريه فيزا يبدو ان المبادره
تحولت الى الجانب الروسي اكثر منه الى
الجانب الاوكراني معلومات عسكريه هنا
تتحدث على ان القوات الروسيه فيزا بروجيا
وخاصه في قطاع روبوتينو تغيرت اللعبه
العسكريه واصبح الجيش الروسي يخترق دفاعات
القوات الاوكرانيه هناك حديث عن اختراق
بما يقدر كيلومتر ونصف استطاعت القوات
الروسيه ان تحدث خرقا في دفاعات القوات
الاوكرانيه هذه المدينه حينما نتحدث عن
رابطنا هذه المدينه التي كانت في الكثير
من الاوقات تحت ضغط القوات الاوكرانيه
الان اصبحت تحت ضغط القوات الروسيه وكذلك
المثال في خرسون اما الجبهه الشماليه
والشماليه الغربيه فقواعد اللعبه لا تزال
هي لصالح الجانب الروسي بالذهاب الى
الذهاب الى مارينكا ضغط قوي هناك ربما من
اجل الاطاحه بهاتين البلدتين وهناك تقدم
قوي وباتجاه لمان وباتجاه كوبيانسك ما
يعني ان الاستراتيجيه العسكريه الروسيه
ربما اصبحت اكثر هجوميه من ان تكون دفاعيه
شكرا لك من دنيا مراسل الجزيره نور الدين
الدغير وكذلك من كراماتورست مراسل الجزيره
مازن ابراهيم